if we show you a random shape your eyes
will send the information to your brain
which will then decide what to do with
it perhaps not much
if we show you another shape your senses
will again send it to your brain but now
it might be able to find some related
information that was stored in your
memory you may have forgotten but when
you were young you knew nothing the
first time you saw a particular shape it
was meaningless over time and in search
for order you started to recognize
patterns one day someone gave that
particular thing meaning your mind
labeled it as important and decided to
store it for future use
so next time you see this or that shape
you might want to pause and pay tribute
to the fact that there are more
Connections in your brain than stars in
the universe here to help you organize
inputs thoughts and memories to get you
through life